hi this is Jeff Passan welcome to the
mobile marketing foundation series I'm
the faculty chair of mobile from market
motive an author of a book called
mobilized marketing driving sales
engagement and loyalty through mobile
devices so let's start out and put a
foundation in terms of what is mobile
marketing
well the mobile marketing Association
puts it this way mobile marketing is a
set of practices that enables
organizations to communicate and engage
in an interactive and relevant manner
through and with mobile devices and
networks now that sounds like it was
written by academia and I know the
person who wrote it and you'd be
absolutely right if you made that guess
so let's break down what we mean by
mobile marketing now if you if I were
fortunate enough to get you to open up
my book mobilize marketing you would see
that there's a basic core principle in
there and it is my belief through
hundreds if not thousands of campaigns
that I've been part of and interviews
with literally hundreds of marketers
that everything and nothing has changed
with mobile it is the what that remains
the same we need to sell more stuff it's
the how that's different in the key
points of the definition of mobile
marketing are communicating and engaging
in a relevant manner through what has
become the most personal device the most
personal channel for us to reach our
customers and prospects and as we walk
through these foundation I will tell you
that this really has gone from a
nice-to-have to really it has become a
must and what I promise you is I'm not
going to lay out some some hype and tell
you that everything gets addressed and
everything gets answered by mobile
marketing but what I will make the case
for is that if you're not doing mobile
marketing you are being left behind and
your competitors are likely no pun
intended beating the pants off of you
when it comes to driving engagement
sales and loyalty
let's talk about the cost of not
including mobile I'm not here to hype
this channel I believe that we have some
distance to go to make it everything we
want it to be and I'll as we talk
through the course I'll talk about where
I think things are in maybe the second
inning or the third inning but I am a
firm believer that mobile marketing is
no longer a luxury for you and that's
for a variety of reasons first off let's
talk about the life of a consumer they
expect they reward and they punish
brands and businesses for the way that
they interact through mobile devices the
expectations are that if a consumer goes
to a mobile device they're gonna have a
accurate mobile optimized experience
they're gonna go on a website on a
mobile device and they're gonna see that
things that they expect to see these
store hours directions and and like
maybe what's the promotion on there they
expect to reward and punish those who
are providing these experiences either
in a positive or a negative way and I'll
ask you if you're not doing mobile or if
you're only doing mobile in a small way
what about your competitors if you
haven't you really it behooves you to
take the time to take a look at what
your competitors are doing in this
channel and that's as simple as going on
their website through a mobile device
going in their store and seeing if
there's a call to action if there's a
way for us to engage with that business
through mobile because I'll tell you
that in in a lot of ways there are huge
ramifications for you to be on the
sidelines or relatively inactive and
your competitors doing a lot more and
running the race in a more competitive
way